in other news tonight a scary situation
for one las vegas man after the rv he
was driving caught fire on a local
freeway this morning our nate tannenbaum
drove by the aftermath here's what he
found out
54 year old marco rodriguez may be a
lucky man but he's also smart before
taking his wife and kids on any trip in
that rv he wanted to first do a test run
maybe not like have a suit but he says
he heard what sounded like a pop as he
was driving south of the 95 515 in
henderson decided to pull over at the
auto show drive exit good idea because
the rv was soon engulfed henderson fire
crews were there lickety-split got the
flames out in a hurry just doing some
final mop up work as i got there marco
says he bought the 1994 rv a year ago as
a fixer-upper project
it only had sixty three thousand miles
on it nathan tannenbaum live local now
rodriguez luckily is okay he says he
didn't want to talk on camera he is
planning on getting another rv but says
this time it'll be a new one